let's talk about la resistance
from the post-millennial half a million
sign up on getter after joe rogan joins
platform with a simple tweet to see joe
rogan destroyed big tech and tore apart
the chains of political discrimination
holding back millions of patriots okay
that might be a little bit over the top
but
as we are talking about the power of
silicon valley and the metaverse and
these tech billionaires any opposition
to this be it you know getter or gab or
whatever is a good thing the
post-millennial reports more than half a
million people have joined getter a
pro-free speech social media alternative
the surge in popularity was sparked by
joe rogan i don't think that's true
necessarily um they say it was sparked
by joker and joining the platform
i think it was dr robert malone and
marjory taylor green being banned i
think it was a snowball and well then
malone goes on the on joe rogan's
podcast yeah yeah i'm on twitter
situation i signed up i'm pretty sure i
signed up and a bunch of i saw some
people signing up tim doesn't want to
get written out of the story that's what
it is no no i i was not the first person
i saw other people saying they were
getting on getter no i know because then
you sent me a message that morning right
before joe rogan said
no i was like i'll back you up on that
you did i said do you know the guys that
get her i wanna it's not like i need to
gain control of the account because what
they do is they and a lot of like minds
did this too where they would they would
take like if someone's got a big account
somewhere else they would go and then
reserve the same name for them so that
someone can't come out and camp on your
on your exactly your profile name so i
saw other people posting they were going
to get her i've done this before but
typically i'm like you know when getter
came out i was like i'm not going to
sign up for another one of these things
man i got too many already but then
after listening to joe rogan's podcast
when i heard dr malone say he was going
to be there i was like i'll i'll claim
my account i'll get on there because
if people are going to be using it i
want to hear what they have to say if
they're getting banned and then marjorie
taylor green is on there of course carl
benjamin is on there then i saw joe
rogan sign up and then i was like oh get
it and then everybody after that once
joe rogers was open but it was his
podcast that did it when i heard his
podcast and malone said he was on it
that's when i was like i'm gonna look
this up i'm gonna see what's up so i
think that is what drove it wasn't joe
rogan joining it was joe rogan talking
i mean i had better engagement and and
people know that look you know i look i
don't drink i don't smoke i don't do
drugs
i'm on twitter a little bit though
but
i had better engagement on
getter that day or flight actually it's
still going on and even till today i've
been having better engagement on getter
than i've been having on twitter and
that's just because there's more people
out there and so there's a lot of people
in the mainstream media who don't
understand what engagement is and they
don't understand how social media works
and i saw some people tweeting out like
oh well getter doesn't have as many
users as twitter so you're diluting your
brand etc etc by going on these things
like no you you don't get how this works
you totally don't get how this works
when the new york times gets like three
retweets yeah they go oh my gosh it's
flood their notifications are flooded
it's crazy when you look at mainstream
celebrities and they get no interactions
there are a few people who work for
these big media companies that i know
and i'm like yo their accounts are so
fake they they they get followers um
because they're put on i can always tell
dude suggested user lists i can always
tell when people sign up for twitter
they're like follow this person they go
okay and then no one cares the person
has to say well this is the um this is
uh the reuben ratio didn't ruben come up
with that what is that so it was the it
was the reuben ratio where it's the
amount of followers you have versus the
amount of engagement you get ah i've not
heard that yeah so if you have so all
and if you look at like um like an
anderson cooper right like he has a
really bad reuben ratio because he'll
have like three million followers no one
gets 20 retweets yeah and then for me i
make some ish post about random garbage
and get like a thousand retweets exactly
and then people in media believe it's
real and then everyone who retweets it's
in on the joke i really love that the
funny thing is
so many uh
i said lol joe biden is so dumb haha got
him or something and then m-e-a-w-w runs
the story like tim poole was slammed i'm
like it was a like isn't it obvious
these people yet like that my tweets are
garbled nonsense it's kind of this weird
dynamic where
they've decided to turn
so you understand like if you're not
someone who's part of the program right
if you're if you're not on team just
look up right
um
you're you're you're a zoo animal right
like you're an exhibit to them it's what
i i remember there was one time where
cernovich and i were just randomly
joking around about how ugly cargo
shorts are and we got written up they're
like
the right wing has launched an attack
campaign on cargo shorts how dare they
and like it's like this thought piece
and they were trying to explain how like
right-wing ideology led to anti and i'm
like guys it was
like it's just we're just messing around
hey hey there's nothing wrong with cargo
short is everything wrong i want you
guys real quick i want to say something
important two things completely disagree
uh technically three things twitter does
not drive engagement so this is this was
true back when i worked at vice and
fusion they don't like i think
i'm not sure if they did but i'm pretty
sure folks engagement on twitter on
twitter but yeah fusion was like we
don't care for our twitter button
because nobody clicks links on twitter
to go out nope so there's a but here's
the important thing on getter check this
out dailymail has signed up for an
account this is big they got 384 000
followers i don't know how many are
actual followers on getter because they
do this thing where they just say you
have followers on twitter for some
reason they they migrate your followers
over yeah and then people claim their
accounts or something yeah and i wish
they would i wish they would it's clever
because it's for a startup but i wish
they would at least at least if you're
as the user you could see the
differentiation right that you could see
hey this is real this is here's what's
important though in their latest posts
from january from yesterday aoc's
ex-communications director says biden is
old
as ish and deeply unpopular it's got 164
reposts like retweets effectively 450
likes 36 replies that is really good
engagement the new york times doesn't
even get that engagement on on twitter
get engagement's real it's it's legit
people talk and that's what's important
are you engaging with people but more
importantly
they're actually getting played they
probably wouldn't get on twitter yeah
getters
people are asking me about this they say
they say why are there so many chinese
accounts on getter and this has come up
a lot and that's one thing where
you know i realized because i've been on
getter for a little bit that people
don't realize this that getter was the
first community that came to it was the
chinese whistleblower community and
these guys i went out and spoke at an
event they held actually on the 4th of
july at the world trade center and my
wife and i got up and we both gave a
speech in mandarin to them it's this
massive organization it's all it's
overseas predominantly overseas chinese
that have fled the regime as well as
some that are inside china still that
are now able to use getter and use other
places to communicate and people don't
realize how many of them there are so i
think something like i was i was
watching an interview with jason miller
and he actually admitted that like only
30 some percent of getters user base is
u.s
and the rest is overseas and twitter's i
think is equal to is even less than that
twitter's like 15 u.s i just wanted to
ask you what what makes you trust getter
and are there any kind of guarantees
that they won't become the next twitter
and start censoring people because
there's already some rumors that people
are being censored and de-platformed
from there
are there any kind of guarantees that
that that you're reassured by when it
comes together because i signed up
because i just saw everyone doing it but
i'm of course skeptical i mean i don't
think there's any guarantees on anything
in life was it death and taxes right but
you know i caught and i actually i think
i caught yesterday when you were talking
about this it's your terms of service
right are you being held to are you are
you upholding your terms of service or
are you playing games with some kind of
like amorphous vague ambiguous community
guidelines that nobody can really make
any sense of so give me at your terms of
service okay i'll read this i'll say i
can say this i can't say that etc same
way youtube has terms of service right
they have certain very clearly
delineated things that you can and can't
say okay fine like this is your play but
yours is your playground i'm going to
play by your rules but at the same time
if you're just arbitrarily censoring
people then that's what i'm going to
call out
we read the terms and services they
seemed very legalese and very vague from
our perspective i mean that's how i saw
is is there anything particular in there
that that kind of uh you you saw that's
different than the other platforms um
not specifically no okay i'm looking at
the terms right now uh you may not post
i think a lot of that we we read the
gutter terms the other day they have
like profane can't post well they're
stuff hate speeches banned yeah defined
speech is outright banned is it
proprietary is it proprietary code is it
open source code or proprietary code i
can't find it open source i think it's
it's the term now this is important is
it is it is it criminally defined hate
speech like the police officers
you know i mean there is there is
another country like who's who's going
to be the one that's what i mean are
they going to be implementing the laws
this is are they going to be
implementing the laws from germany no or
is there going to be someone else who's
going to be making those decisions on
what is hate speech and what is usually
the same who's going to be making those
decisions because this is what what
oversight will there be with rumble
though this is the issue because rumble
is canadian and in canada they do have
hate speech laws it comes down to the
state that the company is incorporated
in you got to follow those state laws if
you're going to go by and getter is
incorporated but they don't know but
then rumble is moving to florida right
they're moving their headquarters my
question is
will their move to florida then change
their terms of service it'll change how
they define what's legal in a sense
because even though there's totally
operating the terms are written so they
can stay on the play store in the app
store well yeah obviously you don't have
to enforce them ever that's true
yeah
uh but they check that stuff
well they make excuses i mean twitter is
loaded with adult content
you know it's like hasn't that always
been part of twitter though no i'm
pretty sure it's not allowed i think
it's it's quote unquote not allowed but
they allow it like every social network
they can believe
at any time for any reason dorsey when
dorsey was ceo like he was always very
public that they allowed porn i don't
know if that's true you want to pull
that up see if yeah i think twitter
twitter did use porn i'm pretty sure i
think on twitter it's not allowed i
think twitter has always said that we
allow this because the app store doesn't
allow that really the app store will ban
you if you allow adult content and yet
yet another and this goes back to luke's
theory of the tech overlords have one
set of rules
no no if you type twitter porn into
search there's a lot of twitter porn
accounts coming up i'm not okay well
that's maybe not
focused
stay focused okay we got a job
the question is is it uh against is it a
louder is it against the terms you know
is it against the terms of certain
consensual nudity policy well that's
that's like revenge important yeah
central nudity they're okay with
why does twitter block porn
i think the idea was there you go to
twitter terms of service it's it will
state under this that it it
differentiates between uh consensually
produced
you may vote you may not post media that
are excessively gory or share violent or
adult content within live video or in
profile or header images media depicting
sexual violence and or assault is also
not permitted so does that mean porn is
banned that sounds like you could click
no it's just saying it's just saying
that it can't be in your your profile or
your header right but it can be in your
actual feed
no it doesn't even say anything about
that i don't know
you can't advert
it does not actually
look up the revenge porn policy because
well that's obvious no but i believe
it's mentioned in there
that was that was
it yeah what is not a violation of the
policy look oh i see pornography and
other forms of consensus are allowed on
twitter okay
they are all on twitter all right well
then how are they allowed in the app
store yeah that's a good question and
that's something that we battle with at
mines in the early days like how do you
they just know people it's because
they're the type of because they're out
there the oligarchs they're right there
in the club man the friends of the
friends you are not interesting
interesting
ultimately i think all these sites
should be allowed to have whatever terms
they want expect to get banned on any of
them if it's not your platform that's
one way to go about it i don't trust any
of this stuff especially if the code's
private thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you